hello again my name is mohit basumdar
and i'm one of the global
representatives of pine biotech
and in my current role i'm collaborating
and working with academia and industry
to provide support for bioinformatics
research and
education so along with our hard working
an efficient team we have been able to
work with more than 30 universities
for the past couple of years for
research-based programs and helping
thousands of students to develop
understanding of data-driven research
and life sciences
so in this program what we'll be doing
is that we will be utilizing
some of the uh top rated online
tutorials using the learn
portal uh this has the smart tracking
as well as curated data sets designed
for great
learning experience so after that uh
to tell you uh about the program so in
this program we will combine
online sessions self-guided study
material and practical assignments
for an immersive experience that has
proven to be very effective in our
well-known and respected omixology
programs
so we will learn about important
concepts within biomedical research such
as
infectious diseases cancer research and
learn about
immunology of infection molecular
disease markers
and stages and how these diseases
can be diagnosed and treated so uh
we will be talking about several bio
bioinformatics methods
such as processing of rna-seq data
and like learning about differential
gene expression
and more and finally we will look at the
sample projects and learn how to create
our own project projects with the
bioinformatics method using the public
repositories so by learning about these
major concepts
you will be able to equipped to start
your own project
so about the uh schedule so the upcoming
program like
uh we already have seen the schedule and
we'll go back to the page where you can
download this entire schedule and more
descriptive
one but uh for this uh presentation i'll
just take you through the sessions
really quickly
so that you will understand how this is
uh um i mean how this is going to be
so the upcoming program will focus on uh
ngs transcriptomic data analysis that
include uh performing downstream
analysis and applying data science
techniques and machine learning methods
so we will have almost um i guess four
weeks
to discuss the various aspects of rna
seek data analysis and how
this field of bioinformatics is uh is
amazed uh is continues
it's continued to evolve and amaze us
all
so to start with uh the first session
will be about uh you know learning about
mrna library preparation mapping
mapping on the transcriptome using uh
algorithms such as
top hat high set bowtie 2g
sailfish so we'll be discussing and
telling you that what this algorithm
does and
we will show you how to run this
algorithm so what to expect
from that analysis so that's why i think
tbi info platform plays a very important
route which was discussed earlier
so the first session will be on 19th may
and we'll be looking forward all of you
to join the session
and learn from us and learn from the
resources and come up with a project and
do your internship all of that
so the second session will be about uh
processing transcriptomics data which
will be on 21st uh 21st
may so here we will be discussing
strategies
of mapping exon and junction detection
and then techniques such as
normalization and quantification
and this is all covered in
transcriptomics one
so the transcriptomics courses will be
will be available for those who are
joining
and uh along with the projects but this
course will give you a
great overview of how this entire
ngs analysis is you can start and
you know expect results so after that
on 24th may we have the session on um
project and also it is more about you
know reviewing
so uh so we will be reviewing a
publication so as we
said and discussed and dr harpreet also
showed you that
uh that uh this is a more of a
research-based program
so this in this session we will be
learning about modeling precision
medicine
so here the example is breast cancer
cell lines
and the application of machine learning
so this is a paper
by demian at all modeling precision
medicine for breast cancer
so this paper talks about 70 different
breast cancer cell lines and 90
different therapeutic
agents so drugs so this project also
includes snp data
so microarray data rna seq data
transcriptome which is
and then exam and genome-wide epigenomic
data as well
ma so our focus here will be to
understand about you know precision
medicine
uh that actually revolutionize the way
patients are treated
uh by using precise molecular
information that provides you know
reliable indicators on
the effectiveness of the treatment so i
mean that is one of the major objective
of the
program so in this project we will uh
when
you will be first learning about the
publication and how they did it and then
we have a project
uh on this publication so in the project
we will
leverage cell lines from human breast
cancer
tumor and study that how they
integrate with the other omics data and
the response to various cancer
treatments so what is the response to
the drugs
so as a result you will learn about
various omics data types and how to
integrate them associate them with
phenotypic changes so the response to
the treatment would be the phenotypic
change here and we will be using uh
sophisticated machine learning
algorithms obviously because it's a
complicated multi-dimensional data so
after that uh on 26th
we will be learning about uh loading
these uh
data sets into the into the
python and r and then how can we use
that and prepare matrix and data frames
and create variables and stuff like that
so after that we will be learning about
normalization
and preparation like uh what we can do
for uh to create a pipeline and what
what we expect from the results from the
pipeline
so also like removing zero non-zero
and log scale transformation after that
we will be learning about how we can do
this like
in and see visually so doing the box
plots
scatter plot histograms heat maps
the transformation doing it on the
coding side of things
so after that we will be learning about
exploratory analysis
in rn python so here we start about
pca so from descriptive statistics to
machine learning
so here we will start about exploratory
data analysis and
we will be using coding as well as the d
bind for platform
and then uh the uh you know one of the
major
objective of this program is to learn
about
how the changes in expression
you know affects the phenotype
so differential gene expression is one
of the tools that is
used for this so we'll be learning about
d-sec
algorithm hr and volcano plots
and all of that so that would be on
fourth june
and then we have about the next part
as regression analysis so here because
we are doing comparison
we are making groups and then groups
have uh different
characteristics features so we will be
learning about t
test and anova regression and factor
regression analysis
to get into deeper getting deeper inside
of regression analysis and this is also
very much covered in transcriptomics too
so even if you miss the session
or if you want to prepare ahead of the
session so you can do that so so that
you can make most of the session
so this will be also available for the
participants to do
uh the courses first and then
attend the sessions so that could also
be done
and then we will learn about biological
interpretation and in the context of
single cell so
uh how you can do single cell analysis
and how you can come up with you know
uh keg pathway annotation for
differentially expressed gene
uh do understand about the biological
process molecular function
and all of that so
by this time you have learned about the
different techniques and how
you can apply this to different
different kind of data sets and also how
to understand the biological
interpretation how to interpret the
biological
how to connect it with the biology so
after that uh the next step is to
you know learn about the application of
this technology into different
areas of research so the next session on
11 june is about that
so uh here we will be discussing about
literature review compiling
a data set developing analysis plan and
doing that entire you know
transcriptomics data analysis and how
that
is applicable to neuroscience infectious
disease and oncology so we already
have these projects and we already
discussed about molecular cell precision
molecular cancer
modeling cancer christian medicine but
we also discussed the tcga project
and we also have the projects on
neuroscience and other projects that you
can
uh learn from so during this time we
will be covering
all of that and as elia said we will be
utilizing
these platforms and resources so quickly
just to tell you that
this entire omis logic programs will be
utilizing the learn platform where you
have created a login
so i think uh if you have not please uh
please create a login here it's a free
login so i mean you don't have to join
the program to create a login but you
can
again if you're not joining but still
you can avail a lot of resources and
learn from the resources
and maybe once you're more comfortable
you can think about
what training you would need but if you
are uh
interested and interested in learning
this so i would recommend you to join
this program
now it's a great opportunity uh to join
this because we have multiple
collaborators
and different expertise and we'll be
covering a lot for this summer
because summer is the time where you
will have time and we will also have
time
so here uh the second platform that
you'll be utilizing is the tbi info
platform
uh so which you saw and the third
platform would be the coding platform
and then we will be applying it using
machine learning multivariate analysis
we will be using data mining and
classification algorithms such as
hierarchical clustering
decision trees random forest support
vector machine
um and also uh um
svm and uh so yes support vector machine
lda linear discriminant analysis so we
have all of them
in on the platform and then we will be
practicing the data science tutorials
using the code platform
and we'll be applying that for
visualization and downstream analysis
so this will be the part of this entire
program all of the access will be the
part of the program
so you will be getting access to the uh
to the different platforms as well as
the tutorials from where you can learn
on your own from your browser because
you don't need to even install
uh these um these uh
lab this programming tools and also like
the softwares
so out of this entire uh entire program
you will be able to learn and understand
from the literature
and you'll be able to understand the
steps that is required that are required
to do the ngs data analysis
with uh reproducibility so there will be
a constant accuracy
and you'll be guided by the experts who
have worked throughout
their career and knows in and out most
of the things
but obviously research is challenging uh
each time you get a news question
but however like we have uh quite a bit
of experience working throughout
as india said so we'll be helping you do
these steps
understand from these steps and try to
make the most from the
learning that you get so
uh in this entire process we will be
learning about rn python i said
statistical techniques
how to manage and analyze data develop
communication skills
about how we can present this
information that we have created by by
the form of a slide deck
by the form of a video or by interacting
with us like in in
one of these sessions so the sessions
that we will have
are with the participants and with
the trainer so you'll have a lot of
opportunities throughout that time
hours of time to discuss your own
problems
and come up with uh solutions so we'll
be doing all of that
and to registration about registration
and downloading all of this
at one place so let's just go again
uh to this side uh the transcriptomic
side that we all
went before and then learn about the
process of the registration so here i
have the site open so
[Music]
if
if anyone can share
the link so let me share it
yeah there you go so this is the site
for registration
if you have already logged in so your
name will come up here your name will
reflect
so uh once you're here you can request
for more information
like joining a webinar like the one
you're doing
and you can also start your application
so once you start
your application you come to this place
beginners intermediate and advanced
now uh you have three different
levels to choose from so in intermediate
in the beginners
you will get all of this that we
discussed today
the difference between intermediate and
beginners is that
here you can request for special
one-on-ones
mentor support to help you with any of
your questions
and if you feel like that you need
additional support and that would be
good for you
so that option is there on mentor on
this intermediate option
and then for the advance option is for
someone who would want to work on their
own data
and would want to work on uh using
the tbion for research platform so the
research platform enables you to upload
your own lab data
which is not public publicly available
and you will get a research license to
run though
your analysis and get support for that
so
that's the research license and then you
can sign in and check out so in addition
to all of this
uh uh till tomorrow
there's a special code that you can
apply so you can get a 30
discount on all of that all of the above
so the registration
fees will be reduced the scholarship is
30
for all of you which is an early bird
scholarship so
you can apply that 30 scholarship and
this will be
for available for 105 which is around
700 rupees in
indian currency so please feel free to
let us know if you face any problems
i'll just show you that
how you can apply that maybe quickly